Good evening. I'm Poppy Harlow and you're watching Pew News.
[Brace yourself for the lazer]
[ pop of destiny ]
The first news TANACON, you're sick of hearing about it. I'm sick of talking about it(not really)
The first news: TANACON. You're sick of hearing about it. I'm sick of talking about it (not really)
So let's just jump IN TO IT. Trust me,
there's some pretty spicy news in here that you need to know about.
For those who don't know Tana Mongeau, the youtuber made a meet up
convention at the very same time as VidCon at the very same location as VidCon and,
me ignoring all the lies that were involved,
it was, to summarize it, a disaster. Thousands of young fans were waiting outside in the sun with no food, no water, no cover
for hours until eventually the event got entirely canceled,
disappointing fans that thought they were gonna meet their favorite creators, you know
probably parents and themself obviously; spending a lot of money on travel, hotel and
the ticket themself (itself), which were just rendered useless. The first blame that we were told was that
15,000 people (Tana- 15,000 people)
Just magically showed up unexpectedly, and there's no way for anyone to just
handle that situation
and
a lot of people bought it - I even bought it at some point - but later, it came out that that was a lie from a
police statement from the City of Garden Grove police department saying that 4,000 tickets were sold and only a thousand
people could actually fit in the event.
So then it caused a lot of drama and speculation as to "Did Tana know about this?" "Did Good Times, the event organizer,
did they know about this?" and there was a lot of back-and-forth going on and it wasn't really sure what exactly
went wrong, who is
responsible of these two parties: Was it Tana? Was it Michael from Good Times?
Well now we have the answer [pop] don't you just love a nice conclusion. Thanks to Shane Dawson's latest video. He's a
Close friend with Tana Mongeau,
so we get the inside truth, and sorry- not just the truth about Tana Mongeau, but the *REAL* truth about
Tana Mongeau...
Now the video is 41 minute long and I will [eh] I definitely recommend watching it if you're interested, but I will, however,
summarize it for you. It's basically 30 minutes of incoherent, ugly sobbing.
(incoherent, ugly sobbing)
Does anyone know what she's saying? Scientists are still trying to figure this out. I'm Poppy Harlow and rest assure(d),
I will do my best. We are working around the clock to decipher this
AND YOU
AND YOU BELEEBEE DE BE
AND YOU BELEEBEE DE BE GE GIBBON DESIEN
AND YOU BELEEBEE DE BE GE GIBBON DESIENVDEAS#VING
[ pop ] In my opinion, Shane did a really good job
at giving the most balanced view on this situation as he possibly could.
That being said, they are friends. It's never going to be a balanced
presentation, and in my opinion there was a LOT of Tana
constantly going after Michael and deflecting blame towards him.
She doesn't have many options to play at this point. [Tana- because I don't know should
I have another venue tomorrow?
Should I keep trusting Michael when he keeps *christian channel* me over
I don't understand anything, and you still have not answered my last like ten questions to you
you just keep diverting the subject] Poppy- because you don't let him speak, Jesus Christ, and I'm sitting there like
It doesn't matter. I can agree
that you- she feels betrayed, that, you know, she thought the event would handle it...
It doesn't matter. None of it matters and I'll tell you why, because they both knew.
They both
Knew, THEY BOTH KNEW, both Tana and Good Times knew
[ ??? ]
That the event only held a thousand people,
they both knew that they sold tickets for 5,000,
which isn't surprising!
Anytime I work with a company, the first thing they report is "How many things did we sell?", or "How many
blablabla
did we sell?", "How many units did we turn?", "What profit did we make?"
It's pretty relevant information, and the fact that they're pretending like
They didn't know any of this-
haHAA
We could, but are we gonna be more responsible and drop it from 5,000 to 3,000?
Which is still three times too many people. They both knew, they also knew that the hotel only held a thousand two hundred
um
[ Michael- I have it set to 5,200 right now ]
(mimicking Tana) i LoVe ThAt FoR uS
yeah... Do you love it now Tana? And the final bit that annoyed me so
much: the final clip that is so
annoying to me and I can't- it's
Let's just play it
[ Tana- Like people LOVE to be oppressed outside...  [YES!]
(incomprehensible squawking)
...like they love that s*** ]
Tana Mongeau- "People love to be oppressed outside"
[Tana- People love to be oppressed outside] Tana! Hello, in case you're watching,
I hope you are, I have a message for you: you say in Shane's video
many times that you want to make it right, you might you want to make the situation better,
but you don't know how because it's too overwhelming
[Tana- I let so many people down and I want to make it right but I-
It's crazy. This is not something I ever thought would happen, and I don't know what to do
but I have to make it right] You're in luck, because I know how to make this right and I'm not saying that sarcastically or un-
ironically, here's what you gotta do. Delete your channel. You clearly don't deserve to have an audience.
The people being oppressed
outside was your audience - the people that care for you, the people that paid money to see you. To me,
this is a perfect example of Greed of Ego and Greed of Money being combined and creating this giant mess and, ultimately,
everyone loses... except me because I get content to criticize.
I mean, I had fun :)
[ pop ]
Next news! Every once in a while, a death occurs in relation to a video game
Usually it's in regards of someone playing for 40 hours straight, even playing for days on straight, and lately,
we've been seeing
uuhhh uhh
Movement more and more towards the idea that gaming is something harmful,
the White House, for example, exclaiming that
"video games causes school shootings." World Health Organization classifying gaming disorder as a mental health condition.
We talked about this on this channel, but we haven't seen before a
psychological death related to video games, at least as far as I'm concerned. Until now [News Anchor- Good morning,
we're gonna start this morning by talking about a free online game
after police and a coroner have warned about the risks of it to children.
It's called Doki-Doki
Literature Club, and it starts like a dating game set in a high school and features a group of animated girls in a book club.
Things do turn sinister with characters self-harming and
killing themselves. It's said to be suitable for players aged 13 or over.
It was launched last year and was downloaded 2 million times in the first 4 months.
An inquest will be held into the death of a 15 year old called Ben Warmsley from Bari whose father said the game
dragged his son in] Poppy- So it was reported in the Manchester news that a 15 year old boy was found dead, now his dad and
Coroner have warned about the horror online game he was playing,
Doki-Doki Literature Club. This has been covered in a lot of different media:
"Don't let your child play Doki-Doki Literature Club before reading this." It's a bit late
now, isn't it? A quote from the father is saying that "Ben was growing up fast. It's hard for parents,
but this needs to be highlighted. There is no confirmation yet, but we believe that the game could be linked to Ben's death."
So they're not outright blaming the game for the cause of death. They're just saying that it's a potential cause.
That isn't really what gets echoed through the media and Doki-Doki is the front face of this
uh
sad event because of it. But what I've noticed while reading through a couple articles is that
the description of the game doesn't really fit what the gameplay actually is. You know, I played the game on my channel.
It was very popular; people really liked it,
it's an amazing game in my opinion, and the constant point that's being
reiterated in these article is that "The game will not leave you alone.
It will drag you in." That's- doesn't fit Doki-Doki in my opinion,
but, fine. Then it's pointed out in another article that the game is an online game -
which it isn't, I don't know where they got that from - and the father
describing the game as "the character
befriends and love you and give you tasks to do but if you do not do them
they turn nasty," doesn't really fit either, and
then finally, after reading this: "the game was linked with his mobile phone and he would be contacted by text message during day and night,
often waking him up." That's when I realized...
They're not talking about Doki-Doki Literature Club. They're talking about another game. It's even shown here in another article.
They're talking about
Mystic Messenger, a game where you message people, a game that will give you notifications at random points,
at least I think, that's what I imagine is what he meant - a game that drags you in, a game that's free - it all fits.
It all fits perfectly.
If you go to Doki-Doki's website, the game doesn't lure you in; it's not some sort of con to
portray it as this colorful game and it's really a
massive plot twist to anyone that it's a horror game. People know you go on the website and it's tagged as a
psychological horror, and the first text that shows up is that the game is not suitable for children and those who
(are) easily disturb(ed).
But then I thought it was interesting because, in contrast to these other gaming-related death(s), this game is actually very short.
It's not focused to drag you in or keep you playing or keep you hooked on the game like many other games are designed to
be these days.
And, after this article came out,
another parent came forward and said the same thing - that their child hads- "had problems sleeping, stopped eating,
"there was no clear signs of what would happen."
But, "there were many things happening with my son and Doki-Doki is just one part of it,
but I need the death of my son to have some meaning." Now
I can't possibly imagine what it's like to lose a child and I
don't know the hardship of what it's like to being a parent and I'm not
blaming any parent...
Sometimes horrible things just happen for no good reason.
But in my opinion, one videogame doesn't drive you to do this - at least not Doki-Doki Literature Club -
it's just not a reasonable claim, and, I'm gonna put on my Sonic Sez
meme thumbs up here,
PewDiePie says, as a parent you should be equally focused on what your child is doing online or in front of the computer as
you are focused on what they're doing in their everyday life.
I think a lot of parents don't realize that kids are practically growing up in front of their computers and it's a massive part of
their social interaction. To some extent, it needs to be monitored
to prevent these sort of things from happening. And the fact that the parent in this instant (instance) described
another game and calling it Doki-Doki Literature Club
shows, to some extent at least, that they didn't know what the child was up to, or at least didn't understand it, and I understand
that it's confusing as well,
but it- what really amazes me here is how poorly this was covered by the media
with almost every single news article all pointing to Doki-Doki, when, clearly,
that's not it. What are your thoughts? What are your opinions? I want to hear them.
Let me know in the comments. Kind of a downer.
It's not the most fun- pleasant news to talk about, but I think it's important nonetheless.
And finally, I appreciate all the support on Pew News
[ pop that obliterated the universe and all existence ]  ily ;3